ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY IT IS TUESDAY
MAY SEVENTH AT NINE O'CLOCK WE
DO NOT YET HAVE CORN BUT WE WILL
START AS A SUB COMMITTEE.
WE HAVE THREE RESOLUTIONS BEFORE
US TODAY.
WE'LL START WITH AJ ARE NINE
MISS GARCIA.
WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
I SAYS ENGAGE IN PREDATORY
RESISTING YOU SEE PEOPLE TACTICS
IN CALIFORNIA FOR MANY YEARS.
THE EXECUTIVE ORDER OF AND HAVE
THE PUBLIC SAFETY AND THE
INTERIOR OF THE UNITED STATES
SIGNED ON JANUARY. TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN ELVES ICED TEAS ALL
EXECUTIVE BRANCH AGENCIES AND
DEPARTMENTS IN EIGHTEEN AN
ASSISTANT AND ARREST.
I SAW THEM PLAY TACTICS SUCH AS
MAKING ARRESTS AND SO CALLED
FAITH PLACES LIKE COURTHOUSES.
ANOTHER SHAMEFUL RULES USED BY
EYES IS ANNOUNCING THE SOUTH OF
POLICE AND TAKING FULL ADVANTAGE
OF LANGUAGE.
BARRIERS TO TRADE THOSE TARGETED.
DESPITE THE FACT THAT WE HAVE
TAKEN STEPS TO ENSURE THE SAFETY
OF OUR IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY
THROUGH LEGISLATION.
I JUST CONTINUE TO DEPLOY THESE
PEOPLE TAXES AND WAS THIS IN
CALIFORNIA.
INCLUDING A USING THE DEPARTMENT --
INCLUDING OSHA.
HI THIS RESOLUTION WILL URGE A
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO STOP YOUTH
AND WAS THIS AGAINST IMMIGRANTS
AND TO REVISE THE STEEPLE
TACTICS USED BY ICE.
I WOULD LIKE TO INTRODUCE CHRIS
TIME TO THROW THE COALITION FOR
HUMANE IMMIGRANT RIGHTS TO
TESTIFY.
ON BEHALF OF AJ ARE.
NINE THANK YOU FOR SERVICE
PLEASE PRESS RESPONSIBLE CHIRLA
THE CALL THAT SHOULD REMAIN
IMMIGRANT RIGHTS AND STRONG
SUPPORTER OF THE CHAIR.
NINE AS CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST
IMMIGRANT RIGHTS ORGANIZATION
CHAIR THE RECEIPTS FOR CAN
REPORTS FROM COMMUNITY MEMBERS
AND FROM OUR LEGAL SERVICE
DEPARTMENT ABOUT THE UNETHICAL
TACTICS ICE USES.
AND GATHER INFORMATION AND A
HAPPY IN AT CAP APPREHENDING
INDIVIDUALS POLITICS.
THESE TACTICS INCLUDE
IMPERSONATING A LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT APPREHENDING IN THIS
ITS BYSTANDERS ON CONDUCTING --
I NINE ON ITS AND THREATENING
THE DEPORTATION I'VE INDIVIDUALS
ARE NOT FALSIFIED INFORMATION
FOR EXAMPLE.
IN JANUARY OF TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN ICE CONDUCTED I NINE
NOT IT AT A SEVEN ELEVEN LOS
ANGELES TO CREATE TONIC QUESTION
CUSTOMERS ABOUT THEIR STATUS.
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN ICE
GAVE AN INDIVIDUAL AN ULTIMATUM
TO THE TO THAT INDIVIDUAL.
WHO THEY APPREHENDED IN
SACRAMENTO TO FALSIFY
INFORMATION ABOUT A DOCUMENT AND
IMMIGRANTS WHO HE KNEW OF AND
STATE THAT THEY PARTICIPATE
INCOME ACTIVITY EVEN IF IT WAS
FALSE?
ARE YOU A FACE DEPORTATION.
THESE TACTICS BY SIGNIFICAN WE
HAD A LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
RELATIONSHIP WITH IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES AND THROW PUBLIC
SAFETY OF ALL CALIFORNIANS FOR
THESE REASONS RESPECT FOR THAT'S
FREE AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
RIGHT SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
AND THERE IS AN AMENDMENT I
BELIEVE WE JUST CLEANED UP SOME
OF THE LANGUAGE YOU'RE TAKING
THAT ABOUT YES THANK YOU FOR
YOUR HELP ON THAT.
YEAH THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT BUT WE DON'T YET HAVE
A QUORUM BUT YOU MAY CLOSE AND
WE WILL TAKE A VOTE ON THIS AS
SOON AS WE DO.
DOES RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE WHEN YOU HAVE A QUORUM
THANK YOU.
SO WE WE NEED AUTHORS AND
MEMBERS AND THAT WE CAN.
GET ON WITH OUR BUSINESS
[inaudible]
THIS CARILLO.
WE HAVE BEEN WAITING.
JUST THREE OF SO WE'LL NOW MOVE
TO AJ ARE.
ELEVEN OUR SECOND ITEM.
OKAY GOOD MORNING SIR CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
Q. FOR WAITING -- I WAS IN THE
ELEVATOR WITH OUR DEAR COLLEAGUE
AND I WAS MAKING SURE THAT SHE
GOT TO THE COMMITTEE ON TIME TO
GET A I'M HERE 2% -- AJ ARE
ELEVEN WHICH IS STRONGLY URGES
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES CONGRESS TO PASS THE
DEVELOPMENT RELIEF AND EDUCATION
FOR ALIEN MINERS ALSO KNOWN AS
THE DREAM ACT. TO PROVIDE A
PERMANENT SOLUTION FOR IMMIGRANT
YOUTH AND THOSE PROTECTED UNDER
TPS TEMPORARY PROTECTED STATUS.
AND DEFERRED ENFORCEMENT
DEPARTURE KNOWN AS CD.
R. AJ R. AJ ARE ELEVEN ALSO
SUPPORTS THE HOUSE RESOLUTION --
SIXTH WHICH RE INTRODUCES A
DREAM ACT WHICH WOULD
PROTECTIONS FOR TPS MAN DEFERRED
ENFORCEMENT DEPARTURE RECIPIENTS.
I WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE STAFF.
FOR WORKING WITH MY OFFICE I
WILL BE ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
SUGGESTED CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS
AS OUTLINED IN THE ANALYSIS.
AS AN IMMIGRANT MYSELF FROM EL
SALVADOR UNDERSTAND THE
IMPORTANCE AND NECESSITY FOR TPS
FIRST HAND.
SINCE ITS ORIGINAL INTRODUCTION
IN TWO THOUSAND ONE THE DREAM
ACT AIMS TO PROVIDE A MULTI
PHASE MULTI PHASE PROCESS FOR
QUALIFYING UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANT YOUTH TO SEEK
RESIDENCY AND A PATH TO
CITIZENSHIP.
OVER THE YEARS THE DREAM ACT HAS
BEEN CONTINUOUSLY DEBATED
HOWEVER CONGRESS HAS BEEN
UNWILLING TO TAKE ACTION FOR
THAT REASON.
I AM HONORED TO JOIN THE EFFORTS
OF CONGRESSWOMAN LUCILLE ROYBAL
ALLARD WHO IS MY CONGRESSWOMAN
AND ASSEMBLY DISTRICT.
FIFTY ONE IN SUPPORTING THE
REINTRODUCTION OF THE DREAM ACT
AND THEN ENSURING A TRUE PATHWAY
FOR CITIZEN YOUTH IN OUR NATION.
A STATE COURTS CONTINUE TO ROLL
OUT BOTH DHAKA TPS NDT PROGRAMS
IT IS CRUCIAL THAT CONGRESS
CREATES A PERMANENT SOLUTION FOR
NEIGHBORS TOUCH BY BOTH PROGRAMS
HERE WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT.
IS CHRIS FOR TOP A SONGES WITH
THE COALITION FOR HIM -- HUMANE
IMMIGRANT RIGHTS.
THANK YOU FIRST WITH THIS LONG
TIME NO SEE.
CHRIS RESPONSE WHICH OF OF THE
COALITION FOR HUMANE IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS AND ALSO REPRESENTING OUR
OUR YOUTH ORGANIZATION THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM NETWORK WE'RE
PROUD SPONSORS OF THIS MEASURE --
FOR AJ ARE ELEVEN WHICH ARE JUST
CONGRESS AND THE PRESIDENT
UNITED STATES TO CREATE A
PERMANENT SOLUTION OP FOR THESE
INDIVIDUALS.
ARE AS THE SOME THE ONE
MENTIONED SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND
ONE VARIOUS VERSIONS OF THE
DREAM ACT HAVE BEEN INTRODUCED
IN CONGRESS YET THEY HAVE FAILED
TO PASS ANY SIGNIFICANT
LEGISLATION.
ARE THOSE VERSIONS ARE IN THEIR
HOUSE ARE IN THE SENATE.
HOWEVER BECAUSE OF THE RECENT
ACTIONS BY THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION TO RESEND
PROGRAMS THAT PROVIDE
CONDITIONAL STATUS TO IMMIGRANTS --
Là OF OUR ARMED THERE'S TWO OF
IMMIGRANTS HERE CALIFORNIA FACE
TREMENDOUS UNCERTAINTIES
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO OVER
200-200-75000 IMMIGRANTS WHO
COULD BENEFIT FROM THIS
PERMANENT SOLUTION.
IF CONGRESS WAS TO ACT TWENTY
FIVE TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS GRADUATE
FROM HIGH SCHOOL EVERY YEAR FOR
THESE REASONS WE ASK FOR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
RIGHT SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE.
I WILL -- FIRST OFF. SEVEN THE
COURT CALL THE ROLL PLEASE STONE
HERE GALLAGHER CHAO.
CHIU AND SALAS [inaudible]
HOLDEN KALRA [inaudible]
KILEY [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE [inaudible]
NORRIS [inaudible]
REYES.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A QUORUM
RIGHT ON THIS RESOLUTION
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SEC THE SERVER NOTHING I THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR.
I THINK YOU RAISE SOME EXCELLENT
POINTS IN THIS RESOLUTION AND I
DON'T THINK ANYONE WOULD
DISAGREE THAT THE CURRENT
SITUATION IS INTOLERABLE.
IN NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED BUT I
DO THINK IT'S AN
OVERSIMPLIFICATION TO SAY THAT
CONGRESS IS UNWILLING TO ACT I
MEAN I THINK THE REALITY IS THAT
THERE ARE.
DEEP PHILOSOPHICAL DIVIDES AND
DISAGREEMENTS ABOUT WHAT SHOULD
BE DONE ABOUT THAT SITUATION.
AND I THINK IT'S REALLY CLEAR AT
I HOPE EVERYONE AGREES THAT WE
WE NEED COMPREHENSIVE
IMMIGRATION REFORM AND YOU TAKE
A HOLISTIC LOOK AT THE ENTIRE
SYSTEM -- YOU KNOW HAVING SAID
THAT I'M ALWAYS A LITTLE WARY OF
RESOLUTIONS THAT.
CALL ON CONGRESS TO DO THIS --
URGED THE ADMINISTRATION TO DO
THAT BECAUSE WE ALL KNOW WE HAVE
CLOSE RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE
CONGRESS PEOPLE THAT WE WORK
WITH AND WHEN WE WANT TO URGE
CONGRESS TO DO SOMETHING WE PICK
UP THE PHONE AND WE TALKED TO
THEM.
SO BY DEFINITION OF WE PASSED A
RESOLUTION IT'S NOT URGING
CONGRESS IT'S IT'S YOU KNOW IT'S
A POLITICAL STATEMENT IT'S NOT A
A SOMETHING THAT THAT'S SUPPOSED
TO BE A LEGITIMATE LEGISLATIVE
TOOL. FOR US SO I'M ALWAYS A
LITTLE WARY OF THAT -- IN AND
JUST SAY ONE MORE THING -- THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT YOU KNOW
BECAUSE I THINK COULD BE A
BIPARTISAN ISSUE AND I I'D LIKE
TO URGE YOU IS THIS RESOLUTION
FORWARD CONSIDER MAYBE -- FINE
TUNING SOME OF THE LANGUAGE
BECAUSE IF WE DID IT IN A WAY
THAT CALLS ATTENTION TO THE
ISSUE.
AND NOT A WAY THAT CRITICIZES
THE CURRENT ADMINISTRATION I
THINK IT COULD BE BIPARTISAN BUT
IT MAKES IT VERY DIFFICULT TO
VOTE [inaudible]
FOR THANK YOU.
OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS I'LL
TAKE A MOTION THE MOTION IS THAT
THIS RESOLUTION BE ADOPTED AS
AMENDED.
HE WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND WAS KAYLA THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING IT FORWARD.
I THINK IT IS A VERY LEGITIMATE
IN FACT THE NECESSARY FUNDS OF
THIS BODY. TO DRAFT RESOLUTIONS
AND MAKE REQUESTS AS AS AN
OFFICIAL LEGISLATURE OF CONGRESS
OF THE PRESIDENT OF ANY OTHER
BODY WE COULD EVEN BE ASKING
OTHER STATES TO JOIN US WITH
THIS IS THAT IT'S NOT AN
INDIVIDUAL REQUEST IT IS IN FACT
A REQUEST OF THE BODY.
THAT'S WHAT MAKES THIS USEFUL IN
FACT POWERFUL.
AND WITH THAT YOU MAY CLOSE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND I
WOULD ACTUALLY LIKE TO ADDRESS
MR OBERNOLTE IS POINT BUT IN TWO
THOUSAND ONE WHEN THE DREAM ACT
WAS INJURED FIRST INTRODUCED IT
ACTS THE HAD BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
AND THEN SOMETHING TERRIBLE AND
TRAGIC HAPPEN IN THE UNITED
STATES AND THAT WAS.
NINE ELEVEN AND IT COSTS THIS
THE DREAM ACT ACTUALLY BE PUT ON
HOLD AND SINCE TWO THOUSAND ONE
SINCE NINE ELEVEN THIS HAS
CONTINUED TO BE AN ISSUE THAT
HAS BEEN UNRESOLVED.
BOTH OF THE DEMOCRATIC AND
REPUBLICAN SIDE.
BUT IT'S ENOUGH TIME HAS PASSED
AND TO YOUR POINT WE DO NEED TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT COMPREHENSIVE
IMMIGRATION REFORM LOOKS LIKE.
BOTH FOR UNDOCUMENTED YOUTH
PARENTS OF UNDOCUMENTED YOUTH.
TPS RECIPIENTS A SILENT
RECIPIENTS REFUGEES WE ARE NOW
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS
ACCEPTING LAST REFUGEES DUE.
TO FEDERAL.
REGULATIONS AND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THESE ARE PEOPLE THAT
ARE SEEKING ASYLUM IN.
IN OUR IN OUR STATE AND OUR
COUNTRY NOT ONLY ON THE BORDERS
BUT FROM WARS ALL OVER THE WORLD.
AND SO I DO BELIEVE THAT WE NEED
TO FIND A COMPREHENSIVE
IMMIGRATION REFORM SOLUTION THAT
IS BIPARTISAN.
THAT SPEAKS TO THE VALUES AND
MORALS OF THIS NATION AND WHO WE
ARE AS AMERICANS AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR ABOUT.
THANK YOU.
WE DO HAVE A MOTION A SECOND
THAT THIS.
RESOLUTION BE ADOPTED AS A
MEDICAL ROLE PLEASE STONE BY
STONE AYE GALLAGHER CHOW.
CHOW I CHIU.
GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I HOLDEN KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY.
MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I OBERNOLTE
[inaudible]
PETRIE-NORRIS.
NORTH SIDE REYES.
THAT THESE RESIDENTS ONE MORE
VOTE UP PUT IT ON CALL.
THANK YOU.
NUMBER THIS TAKES US TO ESTE ARE
[inaudible]
TO THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS WELCOME.
SHALL I PROCEED PLEASE
[inaudible]
UP.
THIS CHAIR MEMBERS -- YOU HAVE
BEFORE YOU S. J. R. NUMBER.
TWO I'LL TELL YOU WHAT IT'S NOT
ABOUT IT IS NOT ABOUT THE WALL
PER SE WHAT IT IS ABOUT IT IS
ABOUT.
TAKING FUNDS.
FROM PROJECTS AND INITIATIVES
THAT ARE CRITICALLY IMPORTANT TO
CALIFORNIA AND USING THOSE
IMPORTANT FUNDS. TO BUILD THE
WALL THE FUNDS TO BUILD THE WALL.
IN THE PRESIDENT'S BUDGET.
PROPOSAL COME FROM TWO SOURCES
ONE IS THE COUNTER DRUG EFFORT
THE SECONDS FROM MILITARY
CONSTRUCTION.
TERMS ACCOUNT OF DRUG EFFORT
EVERY YEAR THE ADMINISTRATION
WHETHER IT'S REPUBLICAN OR
DEMOCRAT REPAIRS THE NATIONAL
DRUG CONTROL STRATEGY IS
PREPARED BY THE EXECUTIVE OFFICE
OF THE PRESIDENT BY EXPERTS.
IN THIS TIME.
THESE ARE EXPERTS APPOINTED BY
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THIS IS THE TRUMP PROPOSED
NATIONAL DRUG CONTROL STRATEGY
DATED JANUARY TWO THOUSAND AND
NINETEEN NO WE'RE IN IT DOESN'T
MENTION A WALL.
WE DO HAVE AN EPIDEMIC AND WE DO
HAVE A SIGNIFICANT DRUG PROBLEM.
IT'S CAUSING THOUSANDS OF
THOUSAND DEATHS UNITED STATES.
THE WALL IS NOT MENTIONED IN THE
PRESENCE DRUG CONTROL STRATEGY.
IN AN EFFORT TO BUILD THE WALL
PRESENTS TAKEN MONEY FROM HIS
COUNTER DRUG BUDGET SECONDLY IS
MILITARY CONSTRUCTION.
MILITARY CONSTRUCTION NO OTHER
STATE IS HIT IS HEAVILY AS
CALIFORNIA'S HIT TERMS OF
DIVERSION OF FUNDS FOR MILITARY
CONSTRUCTION. FOR EXAMPLE FUNDS.
ARE BEING DIVERTED FROM THAT
NAVY SEAL RESERVE TRAINING
FACILITY IN SAN DIEGO.
OF FROM THE US NAVAL WEAPONS
STATION IN SEAL BEACH CALIFORNIA
MY DISTRICT.
OF TO CONSTRUCT A NEW HANGAR AT
TRAVIS AIR FORCE BASE IN
FAIRFIELD.
OF FUND A C. ONE THIRTY FLIGHT
SIMULATOR.
CHANNEL ISLAND IMPROVE POTABLE
WATER DISTRIBUTION -- THE NAVY
SEAL COMPLEX AND CAMPUS IN
CORONADO.
UPDATE RUNWAYS AND LANDING PADS
A NAVAL AIR STATION IN LA MORE
AND THE LIST GOES ON AND ON THIS
RESOLUTION URGES.
OF THE CONGRESS TO STAND IN
UNITY WITH US HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
TO BLOCK THE PRESIDENT'S EFFORT
TO DIVERT FUNDING FROM THE
COUNTER DRUG BUDGET AND MILITARY
CONSTRUCTION.
THANK YOU MISTER.
YOUR FIRST WITNESS PLEASE.
MORNING MR CHEN MEMBERS CHRIS
RESPONSES WHICH ARE THEY HERE IN
SUPPORT OF SJ ARE.
TO CHIRLA IS THAT ARE STRONGLY
AGAINST THE PRESIDENT'S CHOICE
TO RE DIRECT FUNDS AND RESOURCES
FROM MILITARY TO THE SOUTHERN
BORDER BORDER FOR THE PURPOSES
OF THE FORCING IMMIGRATION LAWS.
IT HAS RECENTLY BEEN ITS COVER
THAT THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION IS
PREPARING TO LOOSEN REGULATIONS
THAT PROHIBIT BELL TERRY
PERSONAL TO INTERACT WITH
IMMIGRANTS.
THIS THE PROPOSAL INCLUDES
DETAINING IMMIGRANTS AND
IMMIGRANT CHILDREN AT MILITARY
BASES WITHIN THE INTERIOR OF THE
UNITED STATES AND ABROAD
INCLUDING MILITARY BASES LIKE ON
TERMINAL BAY CUBA.
MILITARY BASES SHOULD NOT BE
OPERATED AS ATTENTION CENTERS
FOR IMMIGRANTS SEEKING ASYLUM
SHOULD NOT BE USED TO ASSIST THE
PRESIDENT'S ADMINISTRATION
BREAKING THE LAWS AND HOLDING
IMMIGRANT CHILDREN TO DETENTION.
IS FOR THESE REASONS
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE OPPOSITION.
I'D SAY NOT BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
MITHRAS HEY WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AS THEIR SECOND SECOND.
AT THE SECOND THEY GIVE US REST
SENATOR I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS RESOLUTION I THINK
SOMETIMES WE THINK.
WELL WE JUST TALK ABOUT IT HERE
YOU'RE NOT JUST TALKING ABOUT
YOU'RE PRESENTING A RESOLUTION.
OF AND THIS WILL BE DELIVERED
THEM TO CONGRESS.
THAT SO FAR HOLD SHOULD UP
PASSED BOTH HOUSES YES.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS.
RIGHT SINGER CENTER YOU MAY
CLOSE THANK YOU APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS ASSEMBLY WOMAN AN
URGENT AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION A
SECOND THAT MOTION IS THAT THIS
RESOLUTION BE ADOPTED KALRA
PLEASE STONE BY STONE AYE
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NO CHOW CHAO AYE CHU
CHU AYE GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I HOLDEN KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY KILEY NO
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN I
OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE NO PETRIE-NORRIS.
NORRIS I REYES.
REYES AYE.
THAT RESOLUTION HAS BEEN ADOPTED
BY THIS COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
THANK MEMBERS FIRST ITEM THAT
WAS PRESENTED WAS AJ ARE NINE BY.
MS GARCIA STILL LOOKING FOR A
MOTION THAT MOST AND IS THAT THE
RESOLUTION BE ADOPTED AS AMENDED.
DO YOU HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND OVERALL PLEASE.
STONE BY STONE I GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER KNOWN CHAO.
CHAO AYE CHU.
CHU AYE GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I HOLDEN KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY.
KILEY NO MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
AYE OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE NO PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS I RADIUS
[inaudible]
REYES I THAT RESOLUTION HAS BEEN
ADOPTED AS AMENDED BY THE
COMMITTEE ITEM NUMBER ARE SECOND
ITEM A GERALD LEVIN BY MS CURRIE
WAS ON CALL I'M GONNA LIFT THE
CALL BECAUSE OF SOME MEMBERS
PLEASE.
GALLAGHER. TWO FIVE TWO I HOLDEN
[inaudible]
KILEY [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE.
REYES.
REYES AYE.
THAT RESOLUTION HAS BEEN ADOPTED.
WITHIN A FEW MINUTES YEAH.
RIGHT SO WE'RE MISSING MISTER
HOLDEN IF HE WANTS.
TO COME HE CAN ADD ON WE WILL
CALL THE ROLL UP AND FOR A FEW
MINUTES THANK YOU MEMBERS
.
RIGHT WE HAVE THREE ITEMS FIRST
ONE IS AJ ARE NINE BY MS GARCIA.
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE.
THEN AJ.
OUR ELEVEN BY A MISS CARILLO
CLIPS MEMBERS HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE AND THEN S. J. R. TWO
BY SENATOR UMBERG COLLEAGUES
MEMBERS HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE.
THANK YOU THAT COMPLETES OUR
BUSINESS AND WE ARE ADJOURNED